as more and more people around the
country get arrested for leaving their
homes as we approach the 45th day since
President Trump told us to hunker down
for 15 days to slow the spread some
people are beginning to wonder if these
lockdowns are destroying our Liberty
unfortunately our Liberty problems run a
lot deeper than being locked in your
house for a few weeks and both sides of
the aisle are to blame then more
evidence emerges that Joe Biden got
handsy with a staffer in the 90s as the
mainstream media steadfastly and
courageously refused to ask him any
questions about it the government
confirms the existence of UFOs okay and
Nancy Pelosi wants to bribe you with
your own money all that and more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
what are the UFOs that's what I want to
know nobody is talking about it but I'm
a little curious since the government's
telling us there is such a thing as UFOs
please let me know what you think it is
in the comment section I'd be very
curious and of course it's gonna be like
The History Channel guy says it's aliens
but I'd like to know maybe your thoughts
on it too first we got to thank our
friends by the way over at books if you
can't be with your mother this Mother's
Day and chances are you probably can't
then flowers are the perfect thing to
send her I just put in my Mother's Day
orders and they you should too maybe you
can't give mom a hug you can always send
flowers from the books company books
what's books stand for short for bouquet
doesn't that make sense
books are responsibly sourced from some
of the world's finest to eco-friendly
farms even farms on the sides of
volcanoes Wow
so flowers stay fresher longer did you
know that flowers and plants have been
proven to reduce stress and boost
productivity yeah duh also they look
nice and they smell nice having flowers
in the home is just something civilized
people should do so you can send those
flowers to your mom your wife your
grandma a dog mom or you can treat
yourself and I am a huge proponent of
treating yourself to flowers it just
makes everything nicer in the house
send smiles no matter the miles with
books calm slash Knowles that's Bo u Q s
dot-com / Knowles enter code Knowles for
25% off your entire order that's my
Mother's Day gift to you code Knowles
for 25% off at Books calm / Knowles I
think we have fallen from reasonable
lockdown measures into total farce we
did that over the weekend in Oxnard
California in gavin newsom 'he's
left-wing hellscape of california in
Oxnard some people went to the beaches
the beaches are kind of opening up a
little bit in California a 93 year old
couple went to the beach
they stayed far away from everybody
totally socially distanced and they sat
down
on some beach chairs in the sand and a
Mounted Police officer on a giant horse
comes trotting over to them and says hey
you you can't sit in that chair this is
Gavin Newsom is California he ordered
the couple out of the chairs they were
allowed to sit in the sand but they were
not allowed to sit in the chairs because
apparently letting 93 year-old sit in
chairs spreads coronavirus but if they
sit in the sand they're okay here's the
clip I'll narrate because it's a little
hard to hear the audio guy comes on over
there on their horse you can hear a an
onlooker says they're old people not
exactly the most polite thing to say
the 93 year old guy count gets out of
the chair stands up cop says I don't
want chairs sorry chairs are permanent
the sand is temporary because luckily
some younger people are walking over now
saying how old are you it's kind of a
rude thing to ask a woman but you're
saying they're old people officer what
are you doing are you insane
that you're gonna tell 90
three-year-olds they can't sit in a
chair and of course this is insane but
this is the state that we've come to in
these power grab cities that now we look
I get it the leftists and the experts
and the politicians are embarrassed that
they got this so wrong they said it
would be 2.2 million dead in America
they said it may be 4 million dead in
America then they revised that down to
half a million then they revised it then
donar thousand there was a hundred
thousand now they're estimating between
60 and 100 thousand that's good news
right we've lowered the death toll
projections by more than an order of
magnitude but they're trying to justify
it any way they can so they say you
can't go out you can't go to work you
can't go to the beaches even if you can
go to the beaches because obviously
there's no reason that you can't go to
the beaches especially if you're
socially distance you can't sit in a
chair grandma alright this this is
disgusting stuff and if we still had a
backbone as a people if we still have
any sense of Liberty not in the shallow
sense of let me
exactly what I want to do but in the
sense of being responsible people having
the great traditions of Western Liberty
if we still had that if we were four
still Americans damn it we wouldn't put
up with this kind of thing but instead
we're being told from paternalistic
politicians that we've got to do exactly
what they say no matter how arbitrary or
they're going to take away from us even
the few liberties that we still have
remaining that's what we're getting from
Governor Patrick Bateman I'm sorry
governor Gavin Newsom governor Gavin
Newsom comes out and he says look we're
willing to lighten up a little bit on
some of these regs but you have to do
exactly what I say if you don't do
exactly what I say then we're gonna
tighten up again the reality is we are
just a few weeks away not months away
from making measurable and meaningful
changes to our stay at home order that
is a very optimistic point to emphasize
however that's driven by data it's
driven by behavior and as we change our
behavior we can impact the science the
health and the data we have to manage in
augment our behavior and that's why I
cannot impress upon you more to those
Californians watching that we can't see
the images like we saw particularly on
Saturday in Newport Beach and elsewhere
the state of California the message is
very clear right the message is be good
little boys and girls and maybe I'll let
you go to the beach sometimes but if
you're not I'm turning this car around
and we're going straight home
okay daddy Newsom okay well I promise
I'll be a good little boy just let me go
to work please let me maybe walk to the
beach or something give me a break
this guy man he also I cannot watch
gavin newsom speak without getting just
pure american psycho vibes like every
time I know he opened his mouth and he
said look we need a social distance and
change our behavior because then we go
to the beach all I could hear was do you
like Huey Lewis in the news it's not
just about the pleasures of conformity
and the importance of trends it's also a
personal statement about the band itself
that's that's all I'm getting is just
pure pure Patrick payment from him and
it's a psycho
message that he has for all of his
constituents we want to reopen we're
gonna reopen the beaches but you've got
to change your behavior little boys and
girls something tells me our
grandparents would not have stood for
this kind of condescension from the
politicians this kind of arbitrary flex
of power because virtually every
conservative I've talked to has not
disputed that the states have police
powers I'm not disputing that I think
you have police powers especially during
a pandemic no one's disputing that the
local mayor's do or frankly even that
the president does what we are against
is arbitrary exercises in power that
don't do anything to actually protect
the public health and day by day it's
becoming clearer that that's what we're
seeing here there are similar stories
all over undercover cops in Laredo Texas
just launched an incredible sting
operation they did it you know they're
down in Laredo there are a lot of
problems down there okay and they've
taken out the two biggest criminals two
women who had a little private beauty
salon in their house they did it they
shut down people who were helping other
women look nice that's it
forget the drugs forget the crime
they're letting criminals out of prison
left and right but they shut down two
small business owners we'll get to that
in one moment first I got to thank our
friends over illegals who speaking of
legal troubles
I love LegalZoom I've used these guys
since before the Daily wire existed I
trust them for everything on the
multiple small businesses that I've been
involved in in my life and that I am
still involved in one thing that you
really shouldn't put off and that
everybody should do is estate planning
okay I've had a had a will since I was
18 years old maybe even 17 health and
safety is on top of everybody's mind
especially at this moment no matter what
happens you want to make sure your loved
ones are protected that's why Legal Zoom
continues to provide a reliable way for
everyone to set up at the right estate
plan without leaving your home it starts
with finding the answers to your
questions do you need a last will and
testament or a living trust or what
about in advanced health care directive
what about power of attorney right there
a lot of court
LegalZoom sighing resources make it easy
to get started I trust these guys I've
trusted them for years go check them out
use them they're great take an important
step for your family today go to
legalzoom.com to get started on a last
will living trust and more make sure you
enter the code Knowles Kenna wles a
check out for special savings that's
illegal zoom comm code Knowles Legal
Zoom where life meets legal yes the the
authorities in Laredo Texas have done it
they arrested two women in an undercover
sting operation operation Rouge I don't
know operation put some powder on and
comb your hair for violating the city's
shutdown Ana Isabel gastro Garcia and
Brenda Stephanie Mata have been
operating a cosmetology business from
their home because they're not allowed
to go to work anymore people need to
make money we got what is a twenty-three
twenty-four million unemployed right now
at least we've got nearly 20 percent
unemployment so people got to make some
money the twelve hundred dollar check
you got from the federal government not
gonna last you for three months and so
they were taking some clients out of
their homes and the Laredo locked down
says that you can't operate
non-essential businesses to find
somewhat arbitrarily and so the women
get arrested how do they even know this
this business was going on the women
were reported anonymously through the
department's snitch app we've seen these
apps in New York we've seen them all
around the country it's a new app to
turn citizens into government spies on
each other it's the most disgusting part
of the whole story and you're seeing
this spread all throughout the US and
guess what once this pandemics over
guess what's not going away those apps
those snitch apps that culture that
turns fellow citizens into snitches on
one another in both cases an undercover
officer working with the Cova 19 force
made contact with these women asked for
the service so is the total set up right
it's not like the women were out there
passing out flyers saying hey come to my
basement so I can put some blush on you
these cop
went up there set up these women then
charged the women with a Class B
misdemeanor which carries a maximum
potential penalty of a hundred eighty
days in jail and a $1,000 fine for the
crime of operating a cosmetology
business and taking some clients when
they weren't allowed to work two women
have already had to fork up $500 months
for recognizance bonds to be released
from jail
totally disgusting stuff and look maybe
these women will get out maybe some
judge will rule that this was an
outrageous government overstep I hope
that's what happens
but the snitch culture is going to
remain what's so crazy is that Texas is
currently reopening they say that
they're gonna let their lock down an
order expire on Thursday with some
restrictions still in place but Thursday
they're gonna open up doesn't matter the
government is still at the same exact
time going to flex their power
arbitrarily neighbors are narking on
neighbors cops are harassing ninety
three-year-olds at the beach and
teachers are wishing death on their
students yes apparently I thought that
cops booting 93 year old out of their
chairs was gonna be the craziest thing I
saw I thought cops wasting resources on
shutting down cosmetology business I
thought that'd be the craziest thing no
there's a teacher caught on tape in New
Jersey shrieking at her students saying
that she wishes death upon them because
they were throwing a football in a
public park
[Music]
we come over there can we go over there
[Music]
I hope you both die a long painful death
says the teacher to her students the
most worrying effect of all of this you
see it a little bit in the snitch
culture and the apps and everyone's on
edge it's this frenzy it's this hysteria
that is gonna be a longer-term problem
look how easily the American people have
been whipped into a frenzy based on
basically nothing I mean what she says
to these kids here is you're the reason
that we're in this mess you kids
throwing a football around in a park or
the reason that we have a global
pandemic now this just obviously on its
face is not true China is the reason we
have a global pandemic China and the
Wuhan Institute of virology very likely
and certainly the the Chinese Communist
Party which covered it up and allowed
that pandemic to spread ninety-five
percent worse than anyone expected it
would and the World Health Organization
which covered up for China
they're the reason okay not kids
throwing a football in New Jersey but
this woman this crazy woman has been
whipped up into a frenzy by the
mainstream media for sure by the
politicians for sure by the public
health experts who got everything wrong
Zeke Emanuel remember Zeke Emanuel one
of the architects of Obamacare he's the
brother of Rahm Emanuel big Democratic
operative Zeke one of the leading
exalted vaunted experts in the white lab
coat he made a prediction a little while
ago about a month ago that a hundred
million people would have coronavirus by
now trouble with making political
predictions is occasionally you get
called out for them you don't get called
out by the mainstream media they just
let them go and move on but occasionally
some frustrating conservatives act
go back and rewind the tape and see how
they did and it turns out they got them
totally wrong and this kind of alarmism
is part of the reason we're living in
this culture right now we will get to
that in a moment first I got to thank
our friends over at beard supply you
know quarantine is giving people the
opportunity to try one interesting thing
it's giving them the opportunity to try
out some new beard looks right some
people turn to tried a new beard look
think I'll maybe I'll let my facial hair
grow in I'll join the ranks of the
bearded brethren well maybe you miss the
memo because a beard is not just funny
games uh-uh
it's not some fifth-grade science
experiment with Mentos and soda beards
are a sacred art and beard supply is
leading you to the promised land by now
you've discovered that a full healthy
beard isn't just something you can order
on Amazon Prime no way Buster beard
supplies 100% natural oils change all of
that hydrating your skin and hair and
leave you to a fuller healthier better
looking beard I got to tell you by the
end of this ad I think I'm gonna grow
out a beard I I so want to join the
bearded brethren but sometimes a little
difficult beard supply can help feed
supplies offering my listeners 25% off
got a beard supply.com use the promo
code Noel's Kenna wles for 25% off oil
soaps balms grooming supplies beard
supply.com promo code Noel's your beard
can be so much better about a beard
supply.com today Zeke Emanuel one of the
people who whipped everyone up into a
frenzy and the friends frenzy is a real
problem your frenzy is compromising your
Liberty a lot more even than gavin
newsom so Zeke Emanuel comes out on
MSNBC a month ago and he says that we're
gonna have a hundred million cases
within a month right now if you look at
the numbers we probably have a million
kovat 19 cases in the country and if
this is doubling every three to four
days that means that we'll have a
hundred million people who have covered
19 in about four weeks that's a
frightening thought that is a
frightening thought also according to
the official numbers off by 99 percent
his estimate was 100
higher than it actually is according to
the official numbers but what does he
command using if not the official
numbers right he's a public health
official so according to the actual
numbers not the Zika manual fantasies we
have over a million confirmed cases in
the United States just a little bit over
a million obviously that's a lot of
people it's not over a hundred million
though million confirmed cases
fifty-seven thousand deaths it's kind of
difficult to track deaths with corona
virus we've talked about this on
previous shows because if you die with
corona virus you die of corona virus
according to the records and this is
disproportionately affecting people with
serious health problems and who are
older so for instance a former teacher
of mine a very sadly died of corona
virus and he was 97 years old he was
about to turn 98 I think the guy was
strong as an ox and he would have lived
until 105 probably if not for this thing
but it's very difficult to track these
numbers because you're you're talking in
many cases about people who are very old
you're talking about people who have a
lot of health problems so for instance
it's let's say somebody's I don't know
90 years old has stage 4 pancreatic
cancer doesn't have very long to live
probably and then gets corona virus that
death will be marked as corona virus
really you've probably attribute it to
pancreatic cancer or to advanced stage
so anyway very difficult to track but
again we're using the official numbers
so we've got 57,000 deaths
if Zeke Emanuel is right and there are
actually 100 million people who have
this who have not been tested who have
not been confirmed for it then that is
very encouraging that the death rate is
so much lower than we predicted right if
a hundred million people actually have
it in the death rate the total number of
deaths is only 57,000 obviously it's
still a huge number but relative to 100
million that's that's an encouraging
number in any case if the number is
really that high by the way if it's a
hundred million people then we are well
on our way to hurt immunity so it makes
this question why we still have some of
these lock downs if the numbers that
Zeke Emanuel was giving all right
or if
they are wrong either way I don't see
the argument for continuing the
lockdowns the whole point of the
lockdowns was don't overrun the
healthcare system and develop a vaccine
right because you don't want to overrun
the health care system because then more
people die then otherwise would and you
want to have the lockdowns until you can
get a vaccine because then you've slowed
the rate so much then you have a vaccine
and knocks it out we now know we're not
going to get a vaccine within a year or
a year and a half that at which point
the virus will have already spread
everywhere and we know that we're not
overwhelming the healthcare system
because the Javits Center emergency
hospital in New York was empty and the
USNS comfort the hospital ship is is was
empty it was gone so we don't we don't
need to worry about that
yet despite all of that evidence the
politicians double down you want to know
how wrapped up we are in the drama of
the corona virus in the drama of the
lockdown in the drama of orange man bad
yesterday the US government admitted
that there are UFOs and nobody cares US
government came out yesterday and after
16 years of questions about one
particular aerial phenomenon but
obviously decades of other questions
about UFOs the US government actually
came out and said yeah there are UFOs
and everyone said yeah okay who cares
orange man bad what did Trump say at the
press conference well we will get to
what Trump said at the press conference
but first we got to talk about the
aliens or I should should be more
specific the UFOs here is some video
I'll narrate it because you can't can't
really hear that well in the here's just
some clips of what people are looking at
when they talk about these UFOs so it's
this object that the people are calling
a tic-tac is it looks kind of like a
tic-tac it doesn't have wings doesn't
seem to be being propelled by anything
in particular and some Navy pilots have
been able to get it on camera so they're
tracking it you know it's moving in this
kind of weird way doesn't look like a
normal airplane or even a drone it's
kind of turning in the air and
and it just like comes to a stop and
they don't they just have no idea what
this thing is there's another one they
caught it it it was very very high up in
the sky and then it just plummeted and
got very close to sea level and then
just kept flying along the sea level and
according to some of these Navy pilots
they're actually we're a whole bunch of
these things they're like a dozen or
even more and then by the time they
actually went to film them they only
they only caught this one but it's
really weird it's moving in a weird way
and some some of these videos came out
at leaked you know a year or two ago
maybe a year or two before that but some
of them actually leaked as early as I
believe 2004 and were published so we've
already seen a lot of these videos but
anyway the government is acknowledging
that they exist now seems to me that
there are three possibilities here this
could either be US government technology
foreign government technology or to
quote that guy in the History Channel
aliens right yeah you can't discount the
third possibility I mean I don't think
it's exactly the likely one but those
are those are the three options US
government foreign government or aliens
I suspect as I've suspected the whole
time that this is US government
technology the government has been
stonewalling on this for a long time now
upwards of 16 years and they've
determined that there's nothing
particularly classified in these videos
and so you know if there's no risk that
the Chinese or someone else is going to
get this first then they can release
some of these videos that would be one
reason to do it another reason to do it
would be to make it clear that Navy
pilots and other people should feel
comfortable reporting this stuff and
you're not going to seem like a total
kook right I think maybe part of the
reason why some people haven't wanted to
report that they've seen these aerial
phenomena is they don't want to seem
like they're tinfoil hat conspiracy
theorists but if the government does
know that these kind of things exist
then they they want to feel a little
more they want the people who are seeing
them to feel more comfortable reporting
them that would also be truth this is
from a foreign government we don't know
exactly what the technology is or which
government is putting it out there or
more importantly
who is intruding on US airspace because
don't forget we're doing all sorts of
exercises in the skies in in our
airspace if some unidentified flying
object comes in and knocks out some of
our equipment or god forbid one of our
pilots or something that's a huge deal
so I might want to sound the alarm on
that a little bit as well and then the
third option is that they're aliens and
I don't think that's necessarily the
most likely option there are some
interesting analyses of these things
though that are floating around the
internet one piece i retweeted it
earlier is written by a guy who said
okay bear with me here's the craziest
version yet that this is a this is like
an alien or something something we just
genuinely don't know what it is the the
way in which this technology is moving
is that 20 22 times faster than for
instance in f-18 the technology that
we're very familiar with and the analogy
that this author draws is that looking
at this tic-tac object compared to an
f-18 would be like someone on a horse
and buggy 500 years ago looking up at
the sky and seeing an f-18 it would be
about 20 22 times faster than the horse
and buggy
just as the tic-tac is 20 22 times
faster than the airplane we we don't
know what it is it's kind of interesting
and it says a lot about our political
culture right now that we don't care
we're not interested in these kind of
crazy wonders of the world because we're
all busy arguing about the orange man's
press conferences and how bad he is
right I think what was at Chesterton who
said the the world is not perishing for
want of Wonders it's for want of wonder
there are a lot of wonders in the world
that we can look at but we we humans
don't have the capacity to wonder at
them and this actually gets to our
problem on Liberty here which is a lot a
lot deeper than just some governor
taking away some right for some period
of time we'll get to that in a second we
will get to the danger of frenzy the
Trump press conference end the final
knock on our Liberty which is coming
care of Nancy Pelosi first though I've
got to thank you I've got to thank you
for joining The Daily wire and if you
haven't done that yet come on over you
know what you get you get old
shows you get become an all-access
member you get the all-access show which
has been a lot of fun we have a lot of
different tiers now and speaking of
tiers TI ers you should also think of
tiers T EA RS because you're going to
want to contain all of the leftist tiers
in a tumbler before you drown and these
days look there are a lot more leftist
tiers going around because the
Democratic presidential nominee looks
like he got a little handsy and even if
he were aware of what his name is or
where he is he's probably still not a
viable candidate so the tears are
filling up you're not gonna be able to
contain them in one vessel you're gonna
need to luckily we're there for you
we're always there for you right now if
you become an insider plus or all-access
member you can double your tears with
two leftist ears tumblers go to daily
wire.com slash subscribed get started
you get 10% off with coupon code Knowles
that's daily wire.com slash subscribe
coupon code Knowles get the rarest of
all beverage vessels x 2 head on over to
daily wear we'll be right back
we're in this kind of frenzy right now
where the the news is telling us
zillions of people are gonna die and
we're just we're so focused on the
present that we can't zoom out and get
some perspective okay we're like so
focused on the political present we're
even ignoring the UFOs it's unreal if
you imagine what it would be like the
day the government said hey there's such
a thing as UFOs you would've thought
it'd be world news everything would
shutdown would be shocked the president
would come out make a statement instead
they're ignoring it that's like page
seven of the newspaper one thing I've
been trying to encourage since the
beginning of this whole pandemic is some
historical perspective right saying okay
guys let's see we're shutting down the
global economy for this pandemic we've
had pandemics before like the Spanish
flu which was very bad but we didn't do
this we didn't do that we've had other
virus scares zika ebola HIV we should
you know kind of maybe temper our and no
the left doesn't want you to temper any
of your hysteria with with perspective
the one thing the media are trying to
discourage number one is historical
perspective and they won't let you talk
about historical precedent they won't
let you talk about other illnesses if
you say hmm let's compare this virus to
the flu they'll scream and yell at you
and say you're not allowed to do that
why I couldn't tell you why this is the
real threat to Liberty this is why
tyrannical regimes like in fiction or in
reality always want to erase the past
because the past is a great bulwark
against the political overreaches of the
present and so in 1984 by George Orwell
says there was no such thing as history
history was erased there's only the
eternal present in which the party was
always right party is always changing
its narrative the left has changed its
narrative the media changed its
narrative on the coronavirus as they've
been more and more wrong but they just
deny all the predictions they made the
week prior or two weeks prior this is
the threat to Liberty our lack of
perspective and our lack of self control
Trump is not letting the press derail
him though he never does can't stump the
Trump so the press now have devolved to
asking questions that are more or less a
president Trump when did you stop
beating your wife they're now accusing
president Trump not only of being
responsible for the coronavirus because
I guess president Trump was leading the
research in the world on laboratory or
something or he was cooking up bad
batches of bat soup they're not only
blaming him for that they are comparing
it to the Vietnam War so yeah we've lost
a lot of people but if you look at what
original projections were 2.2 million
we're probably heading to 60,000 70,000
far too many one person is too many for
this and I think we've made a lot of
really good decisions the big decision
was closing the border or doing the band
people coming in from China obviously
other than American citizens which had
to come in can't say you can't come in
you can't come back to your country I
think we've made a lot of good decisions
I think that Mike Pence and the Task
Force have done a fantastic job I think
that everybody working on the
ventilators you see what we've done
there have done unbelievable the press
doesn't talk about ventilators anymore
they just don't want to talk about them
and that's okay but the reason they
don't want to talk that was the subject
that nobody would get off of they don't
want to talk about them we're in the
same position on testing we are lapping
the world on testing and the world is
coming to us as I said they're coming to
us saying what are you doing how do you
do it we're helping that so no I think
we've done a great job a great answer
from Trump I would have probably been
testier with this reporter cuz it's such
an absurd question as though President
Trump is responsible for a global
pandemic that started in China has gone
to every country in the world has Trump
responsible for the deaths in Italy or
the deaths in Iran or the deaths in the
rest of Europe or the deaths in the UK
or the dead no of course not is it what
are you talking about and but Trump what
he keeps going back to his he says you
know we've done a great job we did a
great job on this we did a great job on
this we did a great job on ventilators
remember the Ven
laterz until he said that I forgot about
the ventilators the ventilators were the
biggest story it's all anybody would
talk about we need to get more
ventilators and equalness if we don't
have enough ventilators by the way turns
out the ventilators don't even really
work that well according to various
studies that have been done most people
who go on the ventilators end up dying
the ventilators are kind of a last-ditch
effort they don't really seem to work so
even even the idea that the ventilators
were the key to stopping the carnage of
the virus does not appear to be backed
up by evidence but that was the whole
story and then President Trump ramped up
production of the ventilators worked
very well and all of a sudden oppressed
forgets about it it's having memory hole
all of these stupid talking points on
the virus and what Trump is trying to do
is bring that back up it's part of the
reason that he keeps going back it's
this way to saying you remember what you
guys tried to impeach me hey remember
when you tried to say I was a Russian
stooge you'll remember that do you
remember that because you wouldn't if
you're just watching the mainstream
media you've become hypnotized by the
mainstream media
you become whipped up into a frenzy you
lose all perspective and when you're
whipped into a frenzy that's the threat
to Liberty I can't stress this enough
it's not just the edicts that come out
of governor's mansions it's your own
behavior and we are increasingly being
accustomed to behavior that is not
befitting a free people
speaking of unfree people we do have to
check in on North Korea because we don't
know if they have a dictator still or
not
president Trump seems to know something
more about that than he's letting on but
we have Schrodinger's dictator over
there you know he might be dead and
alive at the same time he's in this sort
of suspended State President Trump has
asked on it and he refuses to answer so
yeah in any update on kim jong-un's
health as he responded
when kim jeong-hoon I can't tell you
exactly yes I do have a very good idea
but I can't talk about it now
I just wish him well I've had a very
good relationship with Kim jong-un if I
weren't president you'd be in war you
would have been in war with Korea he
would have been in war with North Korea
if I wasn't president that I can tell
you he expected that that I can tell you
I
I hope he's fine I dunno how he's doing
the relatively speaking we will see
you'll probably be hearing in the
not-too-distant future
but not the planet agenda today how he
mentioned is the Box annuity he said he
didn't say anything last Saturday nobody
nobody knows where he is so he obviously
couldn't have said it if you have a this
is breaking news that Kim Jong un meta
statement on Saturday I don't think so
okay there is the there is Trump's
admission that Kim jong-un is not doing
particularly well is the reporter says
he made this statement on Saturday
because the North Korean government put
out a statement with his name on it and
Trump says he made a statement yeah I
don't think he made a statement mmm from
what I know about Kim jong-un's
condition something tells me he is not
making statements at the moment so it
would seem likely that he is in either a
vegetative state or some kind of a coma
or he's brain-dead I don't you've seen
all of the reports that are all just
rumors but based on what we're seeing
from President Trump's reaction one
would suspect that perhaps he's not dead
yet but he's is in a pretty bad way not
great timing of course amid a global
pandemic heightened tensions possibility
of wars increased particularly with
China and then you have the Chinese
clients State North Korea loses their
dictator so sort of a tight situation
but again their perspective nuance
totally gone
then president Trump it is asked this
question about the economy versus
people's lives and Trump makes an
important point here he says these are
not totally separate questions when
people lose their freedoms that can lead
to death as well it would depend on the
state it would depend on the
circumstances of the state but some
states are you know perhaps a little
early and some states are a little bit
late and the Attorney General I read
that and I saw that and frankly the
Attorney General doesn't want to have
rights taken away cuz you know there are
some people they're not allowed to open
up a store or you're gonna lose their
livelihood and by the way that causes
death also between all of the things
that happen and this has been a big
study you know the fact that people
aren't allowed to have their freedom
causes tremendous amount of
problems including death that's true he
makes a good point this is a point other
conservatives have made is when you have
this false dichotomy between opening up
the economy or saving lives you know
some people are saying I'm not going to
sacrifice lives on the altar of the Dow
Jones that this is a false dichotomy the
economy is people right the economy is
not that only this abstract notion it's
actually people and how we go to work
and how we live and when you completely
shut that down
you see spikes and things like drug
overdoses and suicides and so that leads
to death as well a good point to make
it's an easy way to knock down their
false dichotomy but it's not really the
argument okay
even if freedom even if true Liberty
meant that there's a slightly higher
death rate in normal times generally
speaking it would still be a good thing
in fact we know that there is a good
example of this as is driving around we
have various speed limits in the United
States and we have 38,000 driver deaths
per year we lower the speed limit to 20
miles an hour we would have zero driver
deaths per year or virtually zero and
yet we don't reduce that down to 20
miles an hour because we're tolerating
certain risk because we want to exercise
our freedom responsibly we're not saying
that the speed limit is 400 miles an
hour that would be irresponsible too but
we are saying that we are going to have
a responsible exercise of our liberty
that's going to entail certain risk but
the Liberty is worth the risk
right Americans are losing that idea of
the argument we're only arguing from
this very utilitarian narrow perspective
of how many deaths if if if one extra
person dies then it that's unacceptable
and you know if we save even one life to
quote Andy Cuomo then everything will
have been worth it even though that ends
up costing lives Nancy Pelosi is now
taking this power grab to a new extreme
she's pushing for the universal basic
income and unfortunately the Republicans
kind of let her get away with it because
the Republicans were behind this idea
that everyone should get a stimulus
check straight from the federal
government now Nancy Pelosi is saying
wait a second people can't live on 1200
bucks we should continue to give them
these stimulus checks this you
Universal basic income into the
foreseeable future well I think we
should extend the time I really do I
always thought that was too short a time
I think we should extend the time I
think what you suggest makes all the
sense in the world and then again as we
go forward let's see what works what is
what is operational and what needs other
attention others have suggested a
minimum income for a guaranteed income
for people is that worthy of attention
now perhaps so because there are many
more people than just in small business
and hired by small business as important
as that is to the vitality of our
economy and other people who are not in
the public sector to you know meeting
our needs in so many ways that may need
some assistance as well so there it is
Nancy Pelosi speaking broadly about more
money to small businesses which she
actually was holding up herself and then
more money to the people and this idea
of extending stimulus to everybody over
longer periods of time the ubi has been
entertained by both sides of the
political aisle it's been entertained by
progressives like Pelosi and by people
on the right like charles murray and
even the libertarian Cato Institute has
written in defense of something like the
ubi universal basic income this shows us
something about how we understand
liberty it shows us that hyper
individualist s' on the right and
statist s' on the left have more in
common than we might think that somehow
libertarians and progressives maybe they
have something in common classical
liberals and leftist liberals maybe
they're not opposites maybe they
actually have something in common
everybody thinks he's for liberty every
person around thinks he is for liberty
the wackos in the French Revolution and
the good people in the American
Revolution both thought they were
fighting for liberty obviously very
different conceptions of Liberty the
question is what is Liberty right now in
the United States the focus is on
economic Liberty leave me alone to keep
more of my money leave me alone to buy
the things that I want to buy without
interference and I'll be free
on the left the focus is on social
Liberty leave me alone to sleep with the
people I want to sleep with leave me
alone to change my body in ways that I
want to change my body leave me alone to
define reality in the way that I wanted
to find reality as Justice Kennedy
talked about in the Planned Parenthood v
Casey decision leave me alone to define
my own gender and use the bathrooms that
I want to use both define liberty in a
very similar way actually they both
define Liberty as doing whatever you
want to do following your own desires
following your own passions obviously
they represents a little differently on
the right it's more economic on the left
it's more social but it's the same basic
definition of Liberty they might
disagree about the details but they both
agree on the primacy of individual
desire okay and the trouble with that is
as individual desire grows and gets
unleashed and as the restraints on
individual desire break down the state
grows - this always happens and we never
think it's going to happen but it does
so as the focus on the individual grows
the focus on the family the focus on the
local community the focus on local bonds
of loyalty and unchosen obligations you
know we always talk about consent we'll
talk about consent in a moment only get
to Joe Biden right the things that we
don't choose freely that we're just kind
of born into an obligations we have in
duties that we have and inherited
conventions that we have and traditions
that we have those things go away when
you just focus on the individual and
following individual desires whether
it's on the right or on the left whether
we're talking about globalized free
trade or we're talking about
gender-neutral bathrooms or we're
talking about moving away from your
family or whatever things that everybody
does in this modern society the problem
with that is when you are left with just
a bunch of atomized individuals then
that group is very vulnerable to the
state when you're left with just a bunch
of atomized individuals there's nowhere
to turn and when we're in trouble like a
global pandemic but to turn to the state
because all those other institutions
that we might have turned to before the
family most importantly but the lion's
club the local community the parish the
right those things have been so weakened
that they actually can't take care of
the people so you got to turn to the
state this is the premise of the Obama
campaign's life of Julia this is the
premise of a lot of of thought
experiments in recent years on the right
and the left it's the reason why the
right
sometimes embraces the ubi so societies
that start out very individualistic end
up very statist isn't that strange
you can actually see it if you want to
watch this happen in real time you can
see it in the writings of Thomas
Jefferson and Thomas Paine so eat all
the way back then in the early day is
the American Revolution you see Thomas
Jefferson and Thomas Paine they start
out writing they're like hyper
individualist classical liberal
libertarian sort of right-wing and then
by the end of their lives they're
writing in this very statist way very
progressive way about how we need the
state to come in and provide lots of
things for people
it's not that they flipped it's not that
they're total opposites it's that that's
the natural progression of things I
bring this up because coronavirus is
making this a very stark reality ok
people right now are feeling isolated
they're feeling socially isolated
they're feeling economically helpless
we're all just trapped in our apartments
right and we know from the social
science people have been getting
lonelier and lonelier in recent decades
now we see just how lonely we are
because you know if this had happened 70
years ago we probably wouldn't be
trapped in our apartments alone for a
lot of people would probably be in big
houses in big communities with thriving
local associations and now we just have
less of that you know we're more urban
urbanized we move more to the cities we
are more ready to live alone or live
apart from family and social connections
this is why any authentic conservative
alternative needs to really offer an
alternative here ok conservatives
traditionally had a different definition
of Liberty than we started with that
definition of Liberty that the right and
the left right now both share which is
just doing whatever you want to do
following your own individual desire
that's not the traditional definition of
Liberty from conservatives the
traditional definition of Liberty is
something that you had to earn right so
the
the liberal idea the kind of left and
right classical liberal and progressive
liberal idea is based on this false
premise the man is born free in a state
of nature and he's a free individual in
the state of nature and then he chooses
through consent and a social contract to
constitute a government trouble with
that is that's not actually how any
society has ever developed and that's
not how people are born we are not born
free in a state of nature we are born
into families with obligations we're not
free-floating we're born into places
with duties and conventions and
associations and bonds of loyalty and
we're not free we're slaves to our own
passions little babies are not free
little toddlers are not free they're
monsters who can't do anything to resist
their passions they eat all the cookies
right and what we have to do through for
instance the Liberal Arts in liberal
education is to learn how to make sense
of our freedom and to earn our freedom
because freedom is a responsibility and
we have to learn how to do that to to
pursue the good and govern ourselves and
that's how you have a free society the
less we control ourselves the more order
we'll be imposed on us which means
actually in a way gavin newsom at the
top of our show has a point gavin newsom
who says look I'll let you go to the
beaches but you've got to behave
yourselves or else I'm not going to let
you do it in a way he's got a point
if we cannot discipline ourselves if we
can not think of Liberty as anything
more than just pursuing my own
individual appetites and desires then
we're not going to be a free people well
because we we won't be able to make
sense of our own freedom we've got to
start viewing Liberty is something that
we earn we've got to start thinking
about Liberty as something bigger than
just fulfilling whatever short desire I
have and we know that Joe Biden's not
going to be able to do that because Joe
by all Jove I never does is fulfil his
own desires sometimes a little bit too
much apparently before we go I just have
to point out you know the Biden story
he's got the allegation against him that
he sexually assaulted the former staffer
and the woman doesn't necessarily seem
super credible the story was never
talked about for decades when she
initially came out with it it was not
nearly as egregious as what she's saying
right now obviously the timing is
convenient cuz he's running for
president there was a little
corroboration because her mother
coincidentally called into the
Larry King show the week or something
that that she got fired left the Biden
office to corroborate this issue that
she was having now the accuser Tara Reid
her former neighbor Linda Lucas has
confirmed that Reid told her of the
assault and she says this happened and I
know it did because I remember talking
about it that's what she told Business
Insider so now we've got the accusation
from a former staffer not just some
random person corroboration apparently
from the mother corroboration from a
friend at the time this makes it a much
more serious allegation than before I'm
not even saying it's credible yet I
don't know I want to give Joe Biden the
benefit of the dead just like everyone
deserves due process we know this is a
much more serious allegation than
anything ever against Brett Kavanaugh we
know Tara Reid is much more credible
than Christine Blasi Ford or any of
those other people were and yet the
media won't ask them about it because
the media are certainly not pursuing
truth they're certainly not pursuing the
story they are too busy whipping us up
into a frenzy and they're hoping we're
going to take the bait let's not take
the bait all right that's our show i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
fenders hair and makeup
Nika Geneva production assistant Ryan
love the Michael Knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen